let me start by saying congrats on your
movie i thought you guys did such a
great job um and i know
there's a lot i want to talk about but
ultimately um
no one
will have seen the film yet who is
watching this so how have you actually
been describing the film to people
oh great um it's uh it's a portrait of
uh you know romantic relationship in
turmoil uh i would say um and it's an
intimate drama where they you know this
young couple played by amber and taylor
um go up uh and try and
go up to the woods uh for a weekend and
try and and try and work work it out
trying to figure out a way to save their
failing marriage
the thing about this is
you guys um scripts like this don't come
along that often in terms of
uh really like like getting in there
with characters and stuff so i'm just
curious for the two of you guys um what
did you actually pay to be a part of the
movie
parcels
yeah
um yeah i mean
uh
well it was during
covet so i think everyone directors
actors everyone alike in the industry
kind of accepted that we might not be
working for however many months it was
going to be i know other films that were
slated all got put hold for everyone and
when something came along that was
viable to make and also a script like
this i've been saying it reads very much
like a play it's kind of there's so much
meat on the bone for actors that you
just want to sink your teeth into it and
jump in and with steve leading the ship
i think we are both so excited yeah it
was very yeah i mean that experience i
think we're really lucky to have such a
cool group of people
um because like taylor said i mean
everybody who
all of our friends who were like doing
cool things we never get to see that we
never get to work with at all um were
available so it was kind of it was like
a very unfortunate world circumstance
obviously but like professionally it was
really cool to be able to like come
together with all these people that i
think we've all wanted to work with we
really enjoyed being around so
um that was
that was actually a really wonderful
like silver lining of the experience
the the thing about
i this is obviously an indie and you
guys obviously have limited time and
budget but your performances you guys
are are so good i'm just curious did you
actually have a lot of time for
rehearsal to do this or how did you get
ready
um i mean we didn't meet until we got
there you know we were like it was peak
pandemic quarantine so
uh we like all quarantined we got up
there we created a bubble we socially
distanced within the bubble so it really
actually was not a lot of it was not
very helpful for us to be connected but
i think we like kind of did what we
could we like exchanged some emails
taylor had like 100 questions for me
um yeah
yeah yeah we we were very limited in
what we could do with rehearsals with
being socially distanced we were wearing
masks and this is obviously something
that is built on connection and and the
empathy of these characters that i think
we had to build up this backstory i've
never played a character that had uh
a marital relationship but a
relationship that was this extensive
that went on
uh a full decade and so
we exchanged emails with just every
question under the sun to know like did
we ever have a pet what what is your
favorite this what is the thing you
don't like about this just to see if
there are things that you could use um
throughout the script throughout the
filming that would show that there's a
real backstory to these young characters
uh this question for the three of you i
don't want to be specific as to where
this shot comes in in the movie but
there is a shot in this film that is
very impressive in terms of how long it
lasts the emotional intensity between
the characters
and i'm as i was watching it i was very
very impressed um can you guys talk
about without spoiling it uh the
filming that and steve if you could talk
about you know directing that
it was three a.m
yeah
yeah it was 30 a.m um yeah i think by
that point um i i mean we were also i
don't know pretty comfortable with you
know with each other and who the
characters were and we were very lucky
in the fact that we i mean it wasn't i
guess it wasn't lucky we had scheduled
it to be the last day of shooting so in
that way we kind of you know
you know we left of the angelus forest
and we actually had a day off um where
we did spend some time rehearsing for
the very first time and i think though i
think that amber and taylor were
i think it was time for the characters
to really express to each other what the
hell was going on um you know what the
story was about and who they were to
each other as characters and so in a way
it was
um while daunting in some ways um really
kind of easy and enjoyable um
yeah that that
shot that you're talking about this one
take that was very long it
it felt the most uh like going back to
theater you mean like a a
long scene where you really go through
a roller coaster i mean together
individually and what that is and
obviously everyone knows shooting at
night this was the very last shot of the
entire film as well so as steven said we
really built up to this point um and we
had a couple curveballs as anyone does
shooting thrown our way but it was i
think that was the most satisfying as
well of any of the things because it
felt very cathartic like to kind of get
that out and off your chest because for
so long in the film yeah it's like what
everybody was building up to we also
only did it like twice that i think is
the we literally did it twice and that's
the second time so it was yeah it was
like a really wonderful thing
to end on
um and at that point yeah like we
were so familiar i think and familiar
and our characters familiar with our
characters interact with each other i
think that's like the most connected
that they ever see them
um you know for much of the film it's
just them clashing into each other and i
think for once it's kind of them
like
moving together
um so yeah really
maybe
what was it like for the two of you guys
like the night before when you're when
you know you have to deliver this like
kind of a performance what is it like
the day before are you sleeping at all
are you like really in your head because
there's a lot of pressure
for that scene and that take
i'm actually curious to hear your
responses i i'm genuine i was super
anxious
yeah i was super anxious because we had
been doing the whole thing so there was
so much other stuff to like
give emotional energy to you know what i
mean like we only shot over like what um
like four weeks or something so it was
like
to like be constantly just like trying
to give and like you know it was very
indie style so you just keep picking up
things and like shooting out ideas i'm
like what makes sense i can get this i
know that like to i think kind of build
up to this thing
um i felt like i have not prepared and i
was super skilled
just to be really honest yeah i
i think you always have a different
routine for for different characters and
like
i had a sort of a playlist for walker
that i would listen to all the time but
i just made a recording of all of
amber's lines
i wasn't trying to act out i just read
them out and rather than try and say my
lines with it i think i spent two or
three days prior i would go to the gym i
would go on walks just listening to it
trying to wrap my mind around how i
would be processing everything that was
coming from her and then i knew my words
were down so then just seeing what would
flow out once we
got up into
well i guess you don't want to give it
away
into a space where we're also trying
we're trapped in the space that's
another thing because
it's
both characters at certain points
probably want to exit the scene but
there is no option for that and i think
that adds another fascinating wrinkle to
that see yeah
yeah i don't want to ruin it but i'm
just going to say that i really loved
the ending um it's it's
it's very good i wish i could talk
specifically about it but that's for
another time down the road um i love
talking about the editing process
because that's where it ultimately comes
together so steve can you talk a little
bit about what it was like in the
editing room and what maybe you were
nervous about what surprised you
well i think um well we had a great
young editor um uh and we and bella
gonzalez our cinematographer had shot
beautiful stuff and the actors had
um you know
you know
delivered amazing performances so really
it was up to me to mess up like really
it was up to me to ruin the film in the
edit um actually uh because we had shot
the film i think and it was in the game
they say so it was really just having to
rediscover it right to find it because
you know i think also tonally a lot of
what we were able to experience in terms
of the space between the characters when
they weren't speaking and and
discovering gesture and
power and expression um
and the way they reacted to each other
when they weren't speaking uh was really
apparent on set but then when we got
into the editing we had to then you know
you have to recreate it and to be able
to
recreate space you know was a bit of a
challenge um because it was so organic
and beautiful in real time and then you
have to figure out how to kind of
use it for
but it was all there and
just about you know kind of finding the
pace of it and the feeling of it um
while we were doing it and it was of
course difficult because we were never
in the same room it was all on it was
all cutting
doing notes cutting sometimes zooms and
then finally near the end of the process
we spent we got tested and then
spent like a couple of days in the same
room
my last thing for you guys because i'm
uh basically out of time uh what are you
what are you most excited for like
audiences to see with this film what do
you really want people to know about it
[Laughter]
um
i think empathy you know i think um it
starts off at such an unhappy place you
know it's a movie that's difficult in
that way that the characters kind of we
jump into the characters at their most
unhappiest
um both as individuals and together as a
couple and so
i think you know we try to tell a story
that ultimately is one of including
compassion
um and you know a
conversation about our portrait of how
difficult it is um to have a
relationship and to be in love despite
all of our romantic notions of it and so
i want people to go into that you know
kind of conversation
um
and just see how it reflects back
to them and how how it maybe applies to
their lives
but most but most of all um
i want people to be more empathetic
toward each other and toward themselves
really i want people to because it's
it's incredibly hard to do so and i
think people
did um that most of all
yeah no i agree entirely i would say
the complexity of the relationship i
think is so
beautiful and that worse in film you so
often see binaries right like it's a
happy relationship or saturation
romantic or unromantic and in this you
see that it is everything that i think
it's a more
not more accurate but an honest
display of what a relationship is i feel
like often when you
and your partner when you're seeing
films
it's only a part of it whereas this you
really see
a little of all of it and i think that's
what makes it um so honest at least to
me that's what connected so much and i
hope people uh feel familiarity with it
and it um and it connects
yeah i agree i think
um hopefully
the fun thing about this is that you
know it's the story about people
affecting each other and i hope that
people feel affected by it
um and that you know you'd be reflecting
or
having something
to think about you know in your own life
or in your own world or even just
creatively it was such an interesting
creative experience for us it was very
unique like i said it was pandemic it
was a lot of like trying to work
together as a commandment
that even if it you know hopefully
inspire somebody to do that with their
own
i have to stop there so you guys can go
to your premiere i'm just gonna say down
the road when the movie is coming out uh
more than happy to help you guys you
know ask way different questions uh you
know what i mean um i'm just gonna say
thank you so much congrats on the movie
i hope it's a big hit for you guys